well it's lovely to see you here today I
collect Romanian we saw you last in the
five ish doctors reboot how was it
joining that world again the five ish
doctors was the best fun I've had in
front of a camera until now of course
four years and it's been nominated for a
Hugo Award which is extraordinary and I
wouldn't it would be wrong with me to
encourage everyone to vote for it
wouldn't it so I'm not doing that but to
be nominated in the same category as the
program itself is such an honor and it's
a tribute to Peter Davison whose idea it
was
whose script it was and who directed it
I mean it's a it was such a fun thing to
do and it gave the fans something that
they would otherwise have been deprived
of the fiftieth which is all the doctors
who weren't in the celebratory special
now what was it like joining forces with
Peter and also Vesta McCoy he had in
there as well yeah I was loving to work
with them I mean I've I think I've
worked professionally with Sylvester
have I as an actor I mean I with Peter
because I played a guest part in a fifth
doctor story but he was just lovely to
work with them because you know at their
friends and suddenly to be in a
professional context with them after
years of doing conventions was lovely
we spoke to Paul McGann and he was
saying that the idea which he came from
Peter Davison and that it wasn't
originally going to be actually a good
official part of the 50 celebrations and
what did you feel when Peter first for
the idea to you and what did he feel
what it was embraced by that 50th
anniversary special
well when Peter mooted the idea it was
our way of celebrating and there was not
a glimmer of even when we didn't even
hope in fact we didn't want to be
approved I mean he just sketched out
what he intended to do and I'd seen
something he'd done for a convention in
America explaining why he wasn't able to
go and it was very funny so I knew we
were in safe hands but not for a second
T we think that
the program itself will acknowledge that
this was happening but I think the
groundswell of opinion after a while was
such that it was hard for the BBC to
ignore us so first of all they said well
you can come and film down at the studio
and then of course everybody wanted to
be in it everybody from the current
executive producer to the past executive
producer to the director of The Hobbit
film which Sylvester was escaping wrong
said we have seen jerd Peter Jackson and
Ian McKellen Ian just phenomenal and
Peter's cut it together brilliantly
because we shot a lot more stuff than
you saw but the end result is something
I'm very proud of what was your favorite
part of actually seeing it on TV what
was your favorite memory from making it
and your favorite scene from it well it
was lovely having my family involved
because you know they were excited when
they heard about it and they wanted to
come and film at my house so I work out
the film that family being it and Peter
wrote that little vignette of me forcing
them to watch my doctors two of my
daughters still haven't seen me as
Doctor two of them have watched it and
my third daughter Lally has been
listening to all the Big Finish audios
because I've been doing The Sixth Doctor
a Big Finish now for a long time done
lots of them and Lally is listen to me
almost all of them but the others go
yeah must listen one day and they don't
that's the way it should be I mean what
have you enjoyed most about taking
Doctor Who into that Big Finish audio
world oh I mean it enabled The Sixth
Doctor to live beyond the troubled times
when we were filming it from 1983 to
1986 when the BBC itself wasn't that
fond of the program almost trying to
kill it off it seemed and suddenly my
doctor has gained credence as a result
of the Big Finish take on my doctor
which has taken him further than I was
allowed to do on-screen and I just love
with audio such a brilliant medium
because
we look the same on audio we look the
same the monsters are really scary now
what's been your favorite or the bigger
finish episodes to voice and can we look
forward to more coming from you in the
future of advance it's impossible to
pick out a favorite because as soon as I
say one favorite Big Finish another one
leaps into my mind it's like asking
what's your favorite child
but for various reasons I've always
loved the ones I've done with Davros
because that's been a meeting of the
mind of two clever people some of the
stories I did with Maggie stables
culminating in arrangements for war I
love that one but as I say as soon as I
say one story I think I think of another
one the wrong doctor I love doing that
I'm proud of them all we look forward to
more of those coming from you soon yes
I'm do another one in a couple of weeks
I get told off if I told too much about
what is coming up so I mustn't and I've
just finished a series of three with
Nicola Bryant which were yet to come out
so there's plenty waiting to happen
we look forward to those definitely and
of course we've got as far as the 50th
celebration we knew that piece of
equality was coming as a new doctor and
we had him revealed we in that early
episode we've got more episodes new
episodes coming from him in this new
year what are you looking forward to
about seeing Peter Capaldi inhabit that
role of the doctor well Peter Capaldi of
course is a grown up the last few
doctors have been babes in arms none the
worse for that but it's nice of a grown
up again and at Peter Capaldi's an actor
I've admired for years and as soon as
they said they're charging him as a new
doctor I thought yes what a good idea
it's an obvious shooing really and all
the
gossip I'm hearing from the set is that
he's superb so I can't wait to see it
talking about big things that are
happening one of the other big thing
that's happening at the moment is a star
war movie just tweeted that they've
started filming now there's a lot of
fans out there who've been saying on the
internet that they would love to see you
in the Star Wars movie what do you think
of that
how can after begin star wars course I
would and because we were all sitting
around a big finish when they published
that picture of the read-through we
tweeted a picture of us sitting around
in very similar poses and some people
have got it into their head that was an
indication that I was in the new Star
Wars which sadly at the moment isn't
something that they've approached me to
do but I think they should tell you I'd
love to be in the new Star Wars if you
could be anyone in a new Star Wars movie
what kind of character would you like to
be oh I'd like to be the guy who never
heard of before who comes into Star Wars
and becomes the main character I don't
care who it is
dream on : I mean what is it about Star
Wars that you enjoy as a fan maybe
well because I saw the first Star Wars
when people weren't making films like
that which was why it was so loved at
the time I think there was only 2001
around that dealt with things sci-fi ish
I mean since then there's been a sci-fi
explosion both on television and on film
but that that was magical and and what
they could do with special effects
started round about that time so it's a
it's a wonderful memory and what I'm
hearing about the new one makes me think
it's something that it would be good to
be in I mean Jay James of course has got
a massive catalogue of movies and TV
successfully behind him added hey what
do you think it makes him the right
person to direct Star Wars Oh everything
JJ Abrams does is touched with geniuses
an overworked word but he does seem to
have the knack of transforming something
until yes that's what it should be like
and to have him doing it is
makes us feel very optimistic about it
and of course them we've got people
returning who are in the original three
films and people like Mark Hamill of
Harrison Ford Carrie Fisher Kenny Baker
who's here we've got lots of new actors
young actors well John boyega and Adam
drawn over and various people when we
watch you kind of think about that mix
about bringing back you know the
established stars of the original series
and bringing in new cast as well well
any TV or film franchise depends on two
things one is tradition and the other is
keeping it fresh so the mix of old and
new is what you have to do and it's the
proportions in which you do it and how
well you do it that determines the
longevity of the project but I have no
doubts they know what they're doing
there has been a little bit of a rumor
as well going out there and that
identically treated their photo boots
and that it's got you down on the IMDB
for Star Wars 7 as a character call
Nexus how likely are we to see them what
do you think about that I haven't heard
that no I think you I think before it
got into IMDB it might have been a
brought to me the trouble with IMDB is
that anyone who's logged on can change
it so I promise you I'm not I'm not
being to Pittacus I know nothing we'd
love to see you in a future Star Wars
definitely so maybe 8 or 9 no I'll be
Nexus happy to me Nexus well Colin is an
acci lovely talking to you always liked
so much great pleasure
you